you know what I don't get how someone
could possibly call themselves the
ultimate being without having pressed
the subscribe button for the new world
review thus obviously resulting in
regular durga content being uploaded
straight into their YouTube feed so cars
really was just that one small step away
from godhood
but you guys won't make the same mistake
as he did will year hello and welcome to
the new old review source for everything
anime and manga and it's Jojo Jojo Jojo
Jojo
also known as Jojo Monday I've no idea
why I said that I've ruined it I've
ruined the video already in record time
it's just and this time we will be
examining the big bad dude part 2 and
undoubtedly one of the most common
criticisms that I've encountered
regarding battle tendency embodied
entirely within mr. cars now personally
I'm a pretty huge fan of battle tendency
I think it was a great follow-up to the
saga phantom blood and it really
solidified a lot of the features that
make Jojo well Jojo and in a priest and
error as well with that said there are
certainly a wide array of flaws within
part two many of which I have gone
through in a separate video and most of
which I can personally shrug off and get
past quite easily but the one thing that
really does stick out to me is cars and
the genuine disappointment of him as a
primary antagonist and there's a huge
laundry list of reasons for this as well
as count points for each and every one
of them but some of the more commonly
cited ones are Vega t such as bland
motivation minimal character development
and a lackluster overall impact on
Georgia a lot of which is kind of insane
because he does literally become the
ultimate life form but at the same time
I do completely understand however I
think that all of these really do speak
far more to the core problem of cars
which is that we as readers and Watchers
are mostly unable to form that
all-important connection with him as
character which is very present in I'm
going to say just about every other
primary jo-jo antagonist and let's
examine why this is first up we will
begin with the motivation point because
this really is one of the greatest tools
that an author has at their disposal to
build a great antagonist and it doesn't
have to be anything so profound in fact
in my experience villains often work
better with a less than ambitious
motivation that causes them to act in
grant ways for an in-universe example I
really can't go past your target Kyra
ever his motivation is that he simply
wants to live a quiet life that is
something that most of us can very much
empathize with and combined with his
sickening actions it makes Kyra a
concerning Lee intriguing figure to
follow and without going too deeply into
part 7
reddit the primary antagonist of Steel
bull run is driven by the simple yet
powerful concept of patriotism which
once again is something that many of us
can identify with whether you're a proud
Patriot yourself or you're an individual
that gets very uncomfortable with blind
belief in your nation's self absque
rhyme superiority it really doesn't
matter which side of the spectrum you
fall on because either way it gives you
an in with the character Valentine and
conjures a very solid feeling towards
him and that's perfect I think that's
exactly what we're after so here's what
I want to do I want to identify what
causes motivation is because it is the
easiest thing in the world to say that
he lacks it but that isn't entirely true
it would probably be more accurate to
say that he does possess sound
motivation but it is not one that we as
an audience are able to connect with and
in regards to this we can find a very
clear motivation in causes backstory
which guides something like a ridiculous
one hundred and two thousand years
before the events of battle tendency but
let's also continue to give him the
credit of brief expansion here because a
lot of people will bring up his
flashback as a defense for the character
making it out to be some sort of tragedy
that his clan attempted to kill him and
forced him on a path of like generic
evil as well as stating that he was only
trying to do what was right by allowing
his people to live on the surface and
that would be nice that would be so so
nice if it were true but Koz is
specifically stated to be a power-hungry
genius who longed for nothing more than
just to acquire more and more power and
eventually wish to dominate all of
creation he was not trying to help his
people in fact it stated that his people
living in some sort of utopian peace
prior to his existence and his tribe
attempted to stop him not only ruining
their peace but that of all of creation
cars did not care for his people what he
cared about was the right to rule over
creation and you know in many ways cars
can be equated to Hitler which i think
is a purposeful and interesting allegory
actually but that is the very clear
motivation of cars he wanted more power
and as much domination as possible is
really nothing more to it
it's very standard flat fill and stuff
and typically weak motivation so that
makes his motivation very boringly well
domination are against domination of
role creation and this is one of the
worst types of motivation that you can
ever give a villain because an audience
is almost never able to connect with an
idea like this
other than jokingly for the most part
regular people don't feel a desire or
need for world domination like they do
with other basic aspects of life
such as the aforementioned wanting to
live a quiet existence or the pursuit of
patriotism furthermore as often as it
does tend to get used in media world
domination is not a simple idea you
can't just go me get power than me real
world
I guess you can but if you do then
you're really deliberately dumbing down
an idea that is already difficult to
satisfactorily portray thus making it
even less effective overall which I
would say certainly does happen with
cars so there's nothing really too
fruitful with cars in terms of
motivation he presents very disconnected
existence and it sadly didn't have to be
that way because there was some great
potential here for example keep the
underground existence and lethal
sunlight aspect and then use cars and
The Pillowman to explore the concept of
safe freedom you know the very basic
desire to simply go wherever you want in
this world if all cars wanted was to
find a way to live in sunlight on the
planet's surface and all of these hard
actions spoiled from that cause then we
would already improve this villain by
roughly 1000% because we can all
empathize with wanting freedom and being
able to relate to cars in any way shape
or form would be magnificent but sadly
that was not to be and here we also
might hear the argument made that dude
cars is not human
so why should he be given human features
and true on earth cars is not human but
he and the other pillar men do already
possess innately human qualities about
them so why not go that one little step
further and give him a bit of basic
human motivation as well otherwise you
just have this completely alien
existence that is impossible to connect
with and as a result becomes boring and
forgettable because in terms of
motivation you can some cars up with the
following sentence he is a villain
searching for the thing to put in
another thing in order to become the
super thing that's great that sounds
nice and nice and compelling but of
course this is not simply about
motivation a weak motivation can be made
up for and balanced out by general
character traits
I think the do is a fantastic example of
this putting aside the stuff we learn
about him in part 6 because it's
irrelevant to our experience of him in
parts 103 dears tenure as an antagonist
is quite basic and I have done a video
on do expanding on this idea with our
keys of ritual intentions in mind and my
conclusion is that it just didn't hit me
in the way that it may have been
designed for for a wide variety of
reasons buzz things like the fact that
he is quite blatantly stated to be just
born evil also contributed to this
impression and even with what we do see
in part 6 that now that confirms not
as that idea I just thought is a big old
question mark up but look he's any of
that a problem for dear no not really
because he has this bizarrely charming
persona that is capable of pulling off a
less than solid motivation so that
results in situations where I can never
get on board with what deal was doing
that I can certainly enjoy him doing it
because of his simpler consistent
character traits now back to cars can
his character traits redeem him and my
first response to that would be what
traits the most consistent thing
regarding cars is his ruthless nature
and obsessive objective based Drive
and that is cool I guess it is indeed
something but it's nowhere near enough
to form a compelling existence within
the time he spends on page or screen
which I should also point out is quite
minimal until the climax of part two
which is a big problem a larger problem
know is that just as with the motivation
point cars had a lot of potential for
some great compelling character traits
so for example on multiple occasions he
is actually shown to have some sort of
grand respectful life like when he saved
the puppy or when he avoided landing on
the flower that sort of stuff is very
intriguing and it made me think that
there was more to cars than meets the
eye
but these situations very inconsistent
with cars in general firstly because his
whole schtick is biological superiority
so why does he care at all for any life
other than life on his level is it just
humans that he demonstrates no regard
for if so why because then it gets even
more modeled as after becoming the
ultimate life-form cars demonstrate zero
respect for nature and just willy nilly
kills a squirrel representing a complete
180 shift in personality which might
have been interesting if we understood
what that initial personality was to
begin with and we had something to
contrast this new existence against and
not only that but at a very very late
stage in the game we're also shown that
cars had some potential for twisted
comedy where he Flay's Lisa Lisa like a
guitar which was funny but strange
because up until now he had always been
viewed as this supremely serious being
and it was just so late in the game to
start showing any kind of depth and I
guess you could argue that that is just
causes true nature coming out which yes
sure why not once again though by this
stage it was far too late to salvage him
and more importantly none of this helps
us develop a connection with him I think
the biggest chance we got was the moment
where he saved the dog because people by
and large love dogs and that was a great
way to win deer a villain to an audience
but in retrospect it just seems like
such an isolated incidents accounts were
so little in the building of his overall
character
whatever that turned out to be there's
just very little consistency with
character traits beyond to the boring
unidentifiable one's being stunned
vicious and primarily quiet which now
puts us in the position of having a
primary antagonist with a dull
motivation and a non cohesive and less
than generally compelling character
which you know all combines together in
that moment what cars finds the thing he
puts the thing in the other thing and
then he becomes the super thing which
should be a world-shaking event but
instead it's kind of like yeah I guess
this dude powered up moment and you
might think that there is nothing cars
can do to make the situation worse for
himself and you'd be right however there
is great power within other characters
to make cars even less appealing and it
has to do with his juxtaposition to
other villains in the series so as the
main antagonist upon two cars is very
unfortunately caught in the middle of a
do sandwich as do serves as the main
focus for parts 1 & 3 and so cars ends
up being an underwhelming sort of cheap
supermarket brand meat place
delightfully between two fine slices of
brioche and so anybody who eats that
sandwich is going to remember the bread
very fondly but the meat may as well
have not existed but not only that cause
is actually out Shawn in his own part
which partially comes in the form of
being represented as a collective cars
is one of the pillar men who I actually
think worked quite brilliantly as a
group because there is less of a need to
zero in on them individually however
when everyone is defeated and it leaves
cars on his own it leaves us very
wanting because he really only worked as
part of that collective but if you do
put them in a vacuum and examine them
individually then it's also really hard
to deny the cars is completely out shown
by his servant woman to me in an ideal
world
wamu may have served as a better primary
antagonist of battle tendency because he
just has everything going for him being
a character who commences a fierce
rivalry with our protagonist as well as
being the one who ultimately kills
Caesar which further fuels Joseph plus
Volvo has a simple and great idea of his
own to explore which is honor what he
does is all within the bounds of pursuit
of Honor which makes him so much more
identifiable than cars because even if
we don't necessarily practice it
ourselves there is just something more
compelling about a guy who does his best
to stand by his own strict code of
morality rather than a guy who was
dreaming of dominating or creation it's
just easier to connect with one than the
other
so one Swami was taken care of battle
tenancy felt done to me all that was
left to do
cars and I had no connection to him by
that point so from there things were
just plodding along until he too was
defeated so very unfortunately for him
cars doesn't even prove to be the most
effective villain in his own part let
alone George it was a haul and it
doesn't get any better for cars going
beyond do either because every other
part features such a strong antagonist
that have developed great admiration and
followings within the fanbase and it's
not because we agree with their actions
so much but it's because they possess
everything that cars does not but here's
the ultimate question in the end does
any of this matter I guess one of the
problems with examining a topic like
this is that it does risk taking battle
tendency too seriously when in the end
it is very much a quirky historical
strange tale not entirely designed to be
anything profoundly dramatic or an
exploration of incredibly deep ideas so
if you take battle tendency for what it
is then I think cars is very easy to get
past mostly because yeah you'll just
forget about him and voluntarily anyway
but I don't know for me I think that
cars was a bit of a shame in a series
full of absolutely iconic main
antagonists he's a bit of a stain on
what I would consider one of the better
Georgia pots because we simply cannot
connect with him on any level and I
don't know what else to say this
character is simply a narrative failure
but what do you guys think please let me
know down in the comments below and if
you're keen for some wall charger
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos we'll even
subscribe to the channel for regular
Georgia wander delivered straight until
YouTube feed but for now this has been
the new old review and I'll see you next
time